from The View they say as mediaite
reporting lock him up already The View
gets wild as hosts suggest Trump selling
documents predict he gets 10 years in
prison so I want to give you this
context first here's what they say I
mean short of this judge fundamentally
script the case I don't see how he gets
less than five to ten years he's
literally in this he discusses the
contents of classified information with
people without security clearances and
then acknowledges he can't declassify
since he's not president Heavens they
got him they got him I knew that if we
waited a day the context around the
leaked audio would come out and it would
debunk The Narrative and low it has from
CBS news Iran memo not among the 31
records underlying charges in Trump
Federal indictment it would seem that
the context around this story is
actually relatively clear Jack besovic
tweets doj claims Trump is on tape
showing classified docs on July 21st the
docs have never been found but six days
before on July 15th the New York had an
article where Millie accused Trump of
wanting to strike Iran is it possible he
was just holding the article
Donald Trump had said that he had in his
documents newspaper clippings and other
things like that in the Audio I can
understand even I thought initially it
does sound like he's holding these
documents Donald Trump said immediately
of that recording he's like these are
magazine clippings that I have these are
these are copies of news reports
now it's all started to become clear
Donald Trump did have classified uh
documents to some degree or whatever at
Mar-A-Lago this was in Bedminster they
didn't find the documents why would
Trump get rid of these but keep those it
makes no sense unless
Trump not being charged with the Iran
memo documents the uh the doj not
finding Iran memo documents a story
coming out about Millie and Donald Trump
saying he was holding the story yeah the
most likely outcome is that Trump is
sitting with this reporter and he's like
take a look at these papers you know
this is what they give me and he's
pointing to a story from the New Yorker
and he says I should have Declassified
this I can't now he wasn't talking about
classified documents he was saying the
proof behind the lies he could have
Declassified and debunked the story
so it would seem that everything they're
saying about locking up Trump once again
just another the walls are closing in
bombshell report all lies as predicted
didn't by the way the view like two days
ago in response to Hunter Biden's leaked
WhatsApp messages say that the true
story of Hunter Biden and his father Joe
Biden's corruption was a story of a
Father's Love for his son and overcoming
addiction so while that's their response
to blatant corruption that we're
actually seeing in leaked WhatsApp
messages where Hunter is literally
telling a Chinese official I'm sitting
here with my father send us the money
that gets released and instead The View
jumps on this story without the facts it
all crumbles as it always does and we
play the same reel over and over and
over again let's look I want to pull up
the document from the the Trump
indictment take a look at this this is
how corrupt the doj is
they say that uh Trump will no longer
was president gave an interview at the
office of Bedminster blah blah blah he
was recorded with Trump's knowledge and
consent before the interview the media
published reports at the end of Trump's
term a senior military official
purportedly feared that Trump might
order attack on Country a take a look at
Trump's quote we now know senior
military official is Millie We Know
Country a is Iran it's he said Trump
said well with Millie let me see that
I'll show you an example he said that I
wanted to attack Iran isn't it amazing
if Donald Trump was holding a classified
document the document would not read
Millie accuses Trump of wanting to
attack Iran it would say proposal for
Attack on Iran or Donald Trump you know
Italy's reasons not to yeah yeah I would
say like it would be a document
explaining instead Trump says I'll show
you an example he said I wanted to
attack Iran and then you have the New
Yorker story Millie says Trump wanted to
attack Iran it is it is actually kind of
clear based on what Trump said
he's talking about a news report they're
just lying about everything and here
here we are once again having to call
this out now look I'll say this it's
entirely possible I'll always I'll
always it's not absolute maybe this goes
to court and they're like no actually it
really was a document but they have no
document they found no document Trump
says there was no document the story
just come on this is insane yeah
sometimes you have to take the simplest
explanation which is that the left-wing
media wants Trump to be a terrible
person and I think obviously without
context you can frame anything anybody
says to give it a negative light but in
this case all you needed was very slight
information to make it clear what was
going on the way I describe it is like
imagine there's some kid playing Grand
Theft Auto
and he's talking about his plans
and then that you you take a quote a
recording of a kid playing GTA and it
will sound like this kid's like going to
be a manager like a maniac talking about
stealing cars and kidnapping people and
you're like oh man someone's got to stop
this kid and then you go to his room and
it's just some some 12 year old kid
playing GTA this is basically what they
do because no one can see what Trump is
actually doing they twist the context
listen to the paperwork Trump's saying
he could declassify these papers he was
talking about the story behind the story
yeah the documents behind the story
could have been Declassified he can't do
it now because he's not in office he
doesn't have the documents anymore but
I was just gonna say well the problem
even for the left that loves to jump on
any stuff like this it's the boy who
cried wolf at this point so everybody's
assumption anytime anything like this
gets quote unquote exposed is that
it's just another bureaucratic nonsense
the laughs coming after Trump and Trump
probably didn't actually do anything
that was wrong and this is another one
of those examples where it looks
potentially bad because they're only
revealing part of the story and so part
of the problem is nobody trusts our
institutions anymore so it's the same
thing now we're seeing with actual
corruption with the president that's in
office to be fair can we really call The
View our institution
that's a group of empty-headed people
yes but it's been around for a long time
a lot of people watch it I think I'm not
totally sure there are a lot of wine
moms that have nothing to do and that's
where they're getting their information
so now they're hearing that Trump
obviously a hundred percent did a
terrible thing and they won't look for
the Nuance I think that's the biggest
thing white women Must Be Stopped we're
crazy what can I say can I play this
20-second clip from Family Guy to help
you guys understand the view uh this is
important context and I'm providing
commentary on this clip so I want you
all to uh to watch this clip
uh can we get the audio Yeah audio's on
the wrong Channel
[Music]
hey Stewie three o'clock time for The
View no no no not again
foreign
[Laughter]
I can't watch another second so my
favorite part of the gag is when the
woman bucks and then she gets up and
there's an egg and the camera Zooms in
on the egg very very well done joke
Family Guy that's basically what the
view is so uh FairPoint Phil we can't
call the view one of our institutions
but it is sad that all of our actual
institutions don't look that different
than the view New York Times is posting
pretty much the same content the doj
says the same thing the view says on the
same days it's insane you're you're 100
right and it's something that I've
talked about before is is you'll know
it's not just something like the view in
the New York Times it goes to Teen Vogue
so it's like not just about one
narrative coming from one perspective or
whatever why would Teen Vogue have the
same kind of stories that GQ runs yeah
and they really do they all come from
the same perspective but hold on
remember when Teen Vogue ran that like
Mark's puff piece yeah yeah like what's
going on at Teen Vogue Connie's
everywhere team Vogue ran a what to do
to help your friend who just had an
abortion and they suggested you get
funny movies and pins that support
Planned Parenthood team folk is a
classic they're really helpful and
they're helping but but they they pass
it off as well we are making news
palatable to younger readers so we can
raise more informed people but we only
want them to be informed in our
perspective and that's effectively what
all these institutions do right they
they don't want you to follow no one is
going to issue a correction the view is
not going to come out and be like turns
out there was more context you know we
we jump to conclusions they're just
gonna pretend like they were right all
along or like this never happened until
they think they have some sort of actual
evidence I mean compare this leaked
audio to actual WhatsApp messages one is
clear and one is taken out of context
and they're just they're literally I
mean thirsty for for just a drop of of
something to some way to cast Trump as
the bad guy well and they the problem
with what that that exact scenario just
laid out is that any anybody that
actually reports the WhatsApp messages
with thunderbiden is now labeled
conservative media right so it's like no
no we're not conservative media this is
just objectively what happened the vice
president's son is literally texting
this Chinese official saying we've got
your money if you're but now if you
report that you're seen as right wing so
like I know people real well in my life
that were like 80s Blue Dog Democrats
that were taught to trust our
institutions you listen to CNN you watch
these shows you read Time Magazine and
that support is supposed to be the
reliable forms well now anytime
anybody's reporting the truth they write
it off because it's like well no that's
conservative right wing news and I don't
you know I don't want to get involved in
the political divide so they just take
whatever the regime is saying because
they have these mouthpieces and they
never actually get exposed to the truth
that's why when you tell people like hey
Biden actually said this they're like
nah that wouldn't be real or else I
would have known about it there's
there's a lot of that going on there's
and it's been going on for a long time
when I think it was 2000
18 or something like that I and I was
talking about Biden had said uh that
there that he was going to come after
rifles there were AKs and and and then
AR-15s and friends of mine that are you
know pretty left-leaning we're swearing
up and down no they don't no they don't
no he didn't and I'm like I literally
had to send them links and they're like
they actually had to be like wow okay
well that's a terrible idea for him to
say that because he's gonna I'm like
well yeah but it's you don't know even
what the people that you ostensibly are
going to be voting for are saying so
where do you you know how can you
consider yourself an informed voter so
do you have a moment where you stop
trusting the media like do you remember
oh yeah but it was a long time ago how
was it tell me a yellow cake what was
that yellow cake uranium in in Iraq that
was when I was like okay because
initially like when I was young I I kind
of thought Bill Clinton was cool he you
know he played sax and smoked pot and I
was like yeah that was my you know I was
a kid and so I thought he was all right
and then when when uh when it came out
that he had you know lied under oath and
stuff and impeachment I figured that he
was going to get removed from office
because the president's supposed to be
held to higher standards and then when
he wasn't I was like oh well then that
means that and this is a simple minded
take I understand but I was young that
means the Democrats are the lying party
and the Republicans are the party that
tells the truth and then we went to you
know eight years later we were in Iraq
and I'm like wait a minute they both lie
so I can't trust any of them and the
media had sold both of them as as
acceptable arguments and I I just felt
like and unfortunately the libertarian
party is the party where the guy takes
his pants off on stage
or walks around with a boot on his head
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time